Film Courage: Why screenwriting?
Christian Elder, Screenwriter: That's a
great question to start with. I think it's
just basically two things and one is when when I
was young the thing that came before I wanted to
tell stories which I think is very integral
to to wanting to write screenplays is a is a
love for movies and a love for Cinema and so I
think I just became like a movie addict first
without any sort of concern whatsoever
for the idea of writing a screenplay
just just kind of getting a rush from from movies
and watching movies and talking about movies and
and wanting to introduce
my my friends to movies so
for me I think that was the the the first the
the amuse Bouche on the pallet before I launched
into into storytelling storytelling was something
else storytelling was the the idea that there was
a message that I wanted to convey a statement
that I wanted to say and you usually like and
and that didn't really sort of progress
until I for me I was in my early 20s
I had these ideas and I would see these these
great films from from people that were expressing
at the time for me these kind of subjects
that dealt with things that that hit me in
the heart and in at my core for who I was
a young adult as a young black male adult
and one example of course would be well two
examples would be John Singleton and Spike Lee
and and I and I thought hey I want to tell
stories that have like messages that are
akin to that that have that kind of that that
that that relate to to to to people like me
so that was the impetus and then I went on a
journey of trying to discover how to do that
and and that that entailed
um mining what I love about
the written word and and and and and and and
and that also involves A love of literature
love of Storytelling of all types I think that
that screenplays are usually just elaborate
short stories just unspooled and and in a in a
slow fashion across 12 beats which would make
it three acts but but yeah I hope that wasn't too
long no it was perfect you said something about
mining the written word that's interesting yeah
well it it and what I mean by that is is that um
when it comes to writing screenplays specifically
you're telling us a story in pictures and to tell
a story in pictures you have to use these these
blunt little tools that are called words and you
have to find new and different ways to use those
words juxtapose those words abuse those words even
um to to make a picture out of a scene
if you if you have a scene in which there
isn't any sort of banter if the you don't have two
characters exchanging dialogue you have to create
what amounts to an interpretation or a blueprint
that that the director is going to work from and
the and and and and on all the other attendant
people involved so that is mining the written
word you you have to find the right words to do so
so I mean so even as I speak right now you'll find
this is this affects I think the DNA
of of writers and screenwriters because
I think writers intrinsically are always seeking
even as I speak the right word to use because
when it comes to to writing you're sitting there
you're being still you're being patient if you
are if you were born sometime before 1980 you
were in front of a blank page if you were born
somewhere after 1990 you were you're in you're
in front of a blank screen and you're waiting
you're waiting to get just the right word
to string next to another word to get right
to be correct approximation of what you want
the the the director or producer or even the
reader to take away from the experience of that
scene how long have you been doing this I've been
I've been writing scripts in a scattered fashion
for I'll be told like about like 23 years
and yeah that's long and short 23 years and
so was there a point when you almost walked
away from screenwriting absolutely or should
I ask which time or what happened like like
um I'd say a few times early in the game
especially when it seemed really hard
but the thing that kept bringing me back was
was pretty easy is it wouldn't let me go I think
that's a complex thing to answer
because I think if you intrinsically
feel called to write people say that and it sounds
really pretentious it's like it's like you were
called to be a part of the monastery like you're
a Jesuit somewhere and since this is not I know
it sounds pretentious but it it does actually
exist in and if you if you survey a number of
writers they will they will sometimes use that
phrase because they they find that they can't
they can't pull themselves or wrestle some
wrestle themselves away from the computer
that they have to come back and they have to
work at something because it's nagging at them
and it won't it won't stop nagging at them until
until it's finished and so for me it was like that
and it only was it was only when after a period of
time in which it started to become a little facile
it started to become a little easy that I was
like okay well I'm I'm just going to keep going so
there are other things too there's there's
little lessons that you learn along the way
there's there's examples from from
other writers that you pick up that
give you a really strong skill set
to to to use and to borrow from that
make it real real simple in my mind I could I can
expound on that for like like oh maybe two hours
and that I'm actually not kidding so if we wanted
to get into that but but yeah there's stuff like
that so you found it got easier for you and you
were okay with the fact that there was something
sort of pulling you to do this that it was it was
it almost felt like it was beyond your control
yeah absolutely it's yeah that's
basically what it is if I wanted to
to get a little bit more flowery about it you
know some people some people believe in a higher
power some people believe in a muse so there
there I think that with writing there's always
something that that is pulling you towards writing
it and the story and what kind of stories were you
pulled toward I mean you said there were certain
filmmakers John Singleton Spike Lee that you
wanted to emulate that you wanted to make movies
similar to theirs yeah yeah in the beginning
in the beginning I was very interested
in writing stories that were were kind of
carbon copies of of the kind of stories that they
were telling uh that that soon started to evolve
I started become interested in telling
a little bit more action-oriented
almost elongated well not really elongated
but like a sort of cinematic comic book
ask type stories because I love comic books and
I grew up on comic books and and that started to
become incorporated into the kind of writing I
was doing and all the while as I was developing
my craft I was as usual seeing more movies
more kinds of movies different kinds of movies
I'm a big proponent of of writing styles that
aren't exclusive to what happens in Hollywood
or in America I think that what happens in
Europe and and Britain I think the Hong Kong
filmmakers and writers are excellent I
think for example of course John Wu wonkar y
the European filmmakers Michael Hanukkah
Christoph kislowski Mike Lee these are all
the they all provide a different a different
set of tools that you can also bring and use
and so along the way I found myself almost
kind of coming full circle back to what I
wanted to tell in the first place or the kind
of stories I wanted to tell in the first place
but with a more assured voice with my voice as
opposed to being more of a carbon copy or a copy
Michael Clayton interesting love that movie
um why I love that movie is a couple reasons
I think that that one of the finest filmmakers
and writers and the business is Tony Gilroy is his
his work is indelible the the his screenplays
are extraordinary if you want to talk about
terse terse action suspense drama and and and
and any kind of suspense that feels rooted in
reality as opposed to being too cartoonish that is
Tony Gilroy and if for anyone he doesn't know his
his attach his name to to his films we're
talking the devil's advocate he wrote he
wrote the the the the the the first three
Bourne movies and of course the the gorgeous
and and Beautiful film Michael Clayton
which is basically about a character
about a man who is as I was saying a little
earlier is is stuck in a sort of nomad slant
because he has he has this this he's burdened
by by being able to do certain things that don't
don't that render him anti-social in the world
yet he's still a very useful figure he he's a
commodity and he's he's he's a commodity
that is to the detriment of his of his own
his own well-being in in many ways so love that
film what's really great about that film now
is what it does and what what it Blends
is that it it takes all the excitement
that you get all the boys stuff
that you like if you're a boy
um with with bad guys and and and and and and good
guys and and and good triumphing over evil and and
or and and the gray areas that exist in between
and it marries it with with with drama that is
really really I think socially relevant and gives
a message and hearkens back to a lot of those
70s films and those are the films I grew up on and
where the where the films that I became a fan of
when I was a kid those were
films like Sydney lamet's films
like Dog Day Afternoon or or Serpico or you know
any any really any of those network network
phenomenal but yeah right and and where you were
talking about the the gray area in between and
and sometimes where the gangster in the film
is not actually the worst character in the
end we find out that it was the the one that
had the appearance of sort of the the straight
and narrow but actually where where sort of
their morals got it's interesting I feel like
I'm not even sure where I'm going with that I
know we were watching something moral ambiguity
okay okay moral and that's the word okay
thank you and and and and discovering that
in a character because you it's not always
close it's not always obvious to the the
audience and when we find that the one that we
suspected was the bad one actually had more of
a code of honor or ethics than one that looked
squeaky clean and we thought we could trust so
it's those gray areas and yeah absolutely that's
that's what I that's what I enjoy about that kind
of work I think that that I personally and I
don't think everyone feels the same way but
I feel that work like that that enlightens you
about areas of the human condition is edifying
because you have you you grow an insight and
then you have the potential to take that insight
whether it is creatively or otherwise you take it
and you can potentially evolve yourself so that's
Christian what's more fun for you writing
your screenplays or reading them [Laughter]
I don't sometimes I don't even know
if I like writing my screenplays I I
I'm usually starting a screenplay sucks Brad
part usually sucks when you get in the zone
oh yeah that's it Zone of writing a script
that's when it gets really you you get jonesed
that means that you actually enjoy waking up
at seven to eight a.m even sometimes earlier
like around six and you put on the coffee and
sit down in front of the computer and and keep
keep moving it Forward because you're you're
confident as to where all the pieces fit and
where where you're going and even if you're not
confident that you're it's like you're getting
in the car again after a pit stop running the Le
Mans and you're and you you're going to win the
race if you if you as long as you keep the lug
bolts on the on the tires so so that's that's
that's when it's fun but sometimes it takes a
while to get to that place I do realize that
for some people it never is fun in the process
it's it you can be slogging it out quite a bit and
I do recall when it was for me it was never fun
writing it until I got to the to the second draft
until I got to rewriting then I'd go oh wait
no this is no this is not that bad [Laughter]
I feel like I was like digging through a pile
of trash that I'm salvaging some articles that
didn't need to be thrown away but but but but yeah
that's that's when for me now that it gets fun
I don't take any particular pride out
of reading anything I've written I don't
it's I don't know I guess it it's sort
of like like watching yourself on screen
which is a meta thing to say as this is occurring
I don't I I don't think I it doesn't occur to me
to want to read anything I've written other than
to check it for mistakes or errors and to to make
sure that it aligns properly in accordance
to to structure and and that sort of thing
so writing the first draft at times can be
sounds like energizing but at other times not
well I mean it's energizing when you're like I
said when you're in the zone so the meaning like
so you start writing and for me
and I'm I'm gonna I'm a preface this by saying
because you referenced this before we we start
talking about the debate of of outlining
and when I was when I was a kid or when
I was younger I should say I did quite a bit
of outlining and I learned a specific method
on how to outline from some very reputable folks
and I've abandoned them entirely I don't
recommend that to anyone if somebody's new writing
outlining is absolutely essential in my mind I
know people have differing opinions about that
but it's absolutely essential but I do think that
once you have a grasp of what you're doing that
you can feel absolutely free to get get rid of
it when you're ready when you find your voice
there there's there's a thing it's like it's
like it's like the Picasso analogy it's like
it's like once the rules you can throw them away
Picasso was a fine naturalistic painter at age 10.
okay age ten all right by the time he's in
his early 20s he can start to experiment yeah
saying applies to to screenwriting I believe
so for me I start a script and I have like a
satellite number of notes those notes are usually
jotted down in on something these days they're
in my phone I I I use the note field and I throw
little ideas in there sometimes bits of dialogue
and things like that when they accumulate to
a point and there's a number of these going on
at once I mean a number of story ideas when they
accumulate to a point I open up a a a file on my
my computer and I start I start stringing those
notes together once though I start stringing
those notes together I'll transfer those to a
final draft file and I'll start spacing them out
like I'm piecing together a puzzle like like you
take a puzzle and you start with the edges first
I will go oh this might go like around here in
the story and this might go around here in the
story and this might go around here and then
I repeatedly return to that final draft file
and stare at it and go hmm let's put
something in here and let's put something
in there and let's put something in here and
continually build it based on that rubric
and then when it starts to become something
fulsome and it I start to get energized by it
I might spend more time on it so like two hours
three hours once I'm I'm spending like six hours
a day on it it's happening I'm I'm I'm at that
point I'm in the zone and I'm just I'm I'm like
forgetting sometimes to get lunch because
I'm so and I'm so wrapped up in the story
there you go I believe you've referenced Dorothy
Parker many times where you say the famous remark
of hers I hate to write I love having written we
were talking a little bit about her off screen how
do you relate to that quote well absolutely
relate to that quote writing is is hard
it's tough for a couple of reasons there's two
sides of that coin that the actual activity itself
is is taxing and it requires a lot of
patience and and also it is one of those
chosen vocations where one is likely to suffer
a great deal of critique scrutiny and attack
so all of that together makes it makes it tough
so you have to you have to sort of build a sort of
thick skin now the with that comes the the great
myths of of the writers and and and all the all
the the the writers that I can think of and then
this is cross all genres of writing most of them
have this Aura of strength and promotion promotion
of that strength as a writer and in their writing
and those and the finest examples of it is Dorothy
Parker is a probably one of the one of the the
the the Pinnacles of that of of that idea of
strength as well as someone of course like
Ernest Hemingway Hunter S Thompson James Baldwin
all of these characters convey strength and and
that is a is a quality that comes from having to
deal with the rigors of being a writer of putting
in those hours of spending that time of building
your voice as a writer and to have conviction
as a writer and and it also speaks to something a
little bit that we talked about just a few minutes
ago which was that the character that you were
referring to in Michael Clayton and that is they
don't really fit in this box they don't fit in
that box they kind of there's not really a place
for them but they can't just fade away this is
true this is absolutely true I think that that's
a really that's an interesting analogy and an
interesting point that you're bringing up um
I think that that once you go down the road as
is it I always get I'm thorough and Emerson I'm
confused but I believe it was throw the road not
taken so to speak once you go down the road not
taken a friend of mine used to say it's it gets
a little sketchy down there because the road
not taken is often patrolled by the cops so so
uh once you go down that road don't expect to not
face adversity and don't expect it to not change
you don't expect to not to not make you something
that you don't expect that you're going to be
you will you will more than likely become smarter
wiser you will you will have survival skills that
you probably didn't expect that you would gain
but it will turn you into something else that's
really interesting For Better or Worse yes
you're right I like what you said how going
down this road that that's there's there's not
it's kind of a dark murky Road where you're
not really sure what's in the shadows but it
also is maybe sort of a metaphor for what a
lot of writers have been maybe more alone or
I know Outcast is is not the right word but
they're used to having to be their own
strength well I mean to to a degree I mean like
I I know a lot of writers and I spent a lot
of time around writers this is a whole other
subject matter we can get into this in a bit
but but being alone as a writer is not so bad
because writers aren't really alone it's a it's
a kind of Illusion because writers are besieged
with the often with especially if they're writing
stories they're besieged with with characters that
live with them so and it's this it's this misnomer
to say a writer is alone in fact it's like writers
writers in a sense if you want to if you want
to call them anti-social they aren't anti-social
by I think by by Nature they're anti-social by
choice because they just want to get back to
the people they know [Laughter] or the people
that that they're currently entertained with
and and I think that I think that that's
really what it is um I think also conversely
many writers are extraordinarily gregarious um my
my personal Mo I think is that I have two sides
and those two sides are I can be
incredibly quiet totally bashful really shy
a real introvert and then I swing way to
the other side and I can be incredibly
gregarious and an extrovert and and highly social
and and loud and boisterous and all those things
I don't know what that means and but
I do know that that it that is not
that is not something that is unusual that
that many many writers are fill that mold
what are your core beliefs about pursuing a
writing career that's like huge that is and
what I mean by huge is like there's so many things
there the the the the the main thing is for me
is you just have to be committed and you have to
have passion as a as a writer regardless of what
genre of writer writing you're working on I think
that first and foremost that you have to consider
yourself a writer not a screenwriter but rather
a writer that's just me some people might say I'm
otherwise but you really have to consider yourself
a writer because if you don't understand how
how how to take writing out of the re the
arena of solely just crafting spec scripts
Pilots for TV and and feature screenplays
you're never going to really develop
some Innovative skills at actually doing
those things that catch people's attention
so I think that's very important so that all
falls under the ballpark of commitment and passion
so that means that you basically you you you need
your your friend is a is like is a cup of coffee
and your your your seat in front of that that
computer screen those are your friends and you
better get comfortable with them because you're
gonna need them you have to you have to spend the
time to to learn to do what you want to do and
also this is the other thing it's an excavation
um and it's not an excavation of the
of the work that's in front of you per
se although it can be it's an excavation
of yourself because you start to realize
who you are as a writer you start to realize
that like let's say like we're using a a baseball
analogy you throw a mean curveball you
start to and you go oh wait wait I throw
a mean curveball it's like well let me let
me work on that a little bit sort of thing so
that that's what you start to learn about yourself
but first you you might you might just think
you're just a good shortstop when you begin
before you discover your own peculiar talents
when was that clear to you
that's an interesting question and
that's going to be fun to talk about um
when that was clear to me was I I when I started
writing in general I wrote a lot of poetry and I
enjoyed writing poetry and the craft of writing
poetry and so I thought that maybe it would be
easy to use what I know from from poetry writing
to to develop writing screenplays I I wrote my
first screenplay and I had the great Fortune to
to meet and for a short period of time received
some mentorship from from a guy who who took a
little bit of interest in me a a director from
Old School from Old School Hollywood named Ted
post and he was very very gracious and generous to
to offer to read my first screenplay and he
read in he got back in touch with me and he
said to me goes christian I gotta tell you it's
like I think you got some Talent I think how to
write some dialogue but you have no idea how to
tell a story it's like and I'm like oh wow okay
gee tell me what's really easy exactly and
but thanks and he's like I want you to go out
and I want you to buy this book and I bought
this book called The Art of dramatic writing
the most important book I one of the most
important books I should say and I've read
in terms of my writing definitely the the
book that helped set me off on on the journey
but LA Los agreon I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly and and the book is is not so much about
writing for the movies as it is the the classical
elements of telling story as it relates to
to the plays of Ibsen Shakespeare even a
few more modern plays of of the of the early
the early 20th century such as
on O'Neill's plays and whatnot
and that really started to break down for me what
I understood to be structure but even then I was
still a bit flummoxed on how to find a a way to
have a confidence when I would attack a screenplay
because I was like okay there's this over here
and I have I think I have a good idea of of of
voice and characters and and writing interesting
dialogue but I not so sure how to marry the two
so I had written in one script and and some people
were responding to it pretty well and almost like
a lukewarm fashion but they were like oh it's
got a middle a beginning a middle and an ending
and I stumbled across um a copy of Shane
Black's the long kiss goodnight and I noticed
specifically how Shane wrote his screenplays
these terse little bursts of of word formations
to to convey the atmosphere of of the of the
action lines and the descriptions of each scene
just it was just so exciting to read that and
to and how kinetic it was and how how he sort of
just kind of like broke rules certain rules not
like not broke rules just to break rules but just
broke certain rules so that he could he could meet
certain um objectives in a very targeted fashion
and I thought to myself well like I can do that
that's not I can I see what he's doing I see
the architecture underneath it and I can I can
definitely do that and furthermore I found it
very relayed a great deal to to what it was like
to writing poetry because poetry is often very
um elastic with with with language and with words
and and and and and Shane's work was very elastic
so with with words and sentences and the grammar
with kid paid no attention to grammar really
it was just all about getting you to understand
the scene and so I took that on and I rewrote
that that screenplay that I had and then boom
lots of people were all love that script and
in fact it it it it it it secured me a finalist
position with Tribeca access soon after that and
that's when I knew I was on to something that's
when I realized like hey I can do this now I know
what to do I have I have all my I have all all
the paints in my in in my box of paints so yeah
should someone be fearful with building their
entertainment career or at least cautious
yeah I guess so but mostly be Fearless
because what I mean by that is is that there
are so many forces that want to
strip you of your voice as a writer
um and to make you compromise that voice
to to make undermine that voice and confuse you
into thinking that you should undermine your voice
and that's ridiculous that's
absolutely ridiculous um
the the the the greatest the greatest writers
in screenwriting we we know
who they are simply because
not only when we read the scripts
their voice is is apparent and and
and and Rises to the surface but when we we
see the the finished products it's apparent
I mean it's like how would you how do you how
do you separate I mean the sound of Tarantino
you know I mean it's like you know the
sound of Diablo Cody you the sound of
of Spike Lee I mean these people have sounds
that's your voice and if you're not working
you if you're not sharpening your quiver
to towards that to towards that direction
then you're not going to ever sort of stand out
from the crowd because that's what ultimately is
the goal that's what makes you if we're going
back to our Michael Clayton analogy that makes
you the the the commodity that cannot be um
avoided that that people have to come to in
the end it's going well we need him to do this
we need we need to call we need to call up um um
um oh I'm forgetting her name is it Phoebe
Waller Bridge we need to call her to punch
up a script because we need that voice
we need that voice and and and and and
and all you need to do is say her name and
what her voice means to that to that project
it is it is absolutely absolutely Paramount
that every writer get to that space
because then people agents producers
Executives they're they're they're
they get bombarded with crap they get
bombarded with a lot of the same of this
are a lot of like this or or or people
people that sound like Sam back people
that's like this people like that's that that
want to be David peoples people that you know
and they don't really want that they want you
they want to know who you are they want something
that's so unique and that that they can go oh
well nobody else has that so this is this is the
One-Stop shop where you can go to it's a you only
can go to that store to get that that's it you
said I think writing screenplays specifically is
a love for the art storytelling yeah yeah and that
sort of dovetails to what I was discussing before
a little bit with mining the written word but
um yeah it's when I'm but also just to elaborate
on that it's really the classic it's the classic
example of having that that command of telling a
story around a campfire and to take people through
a journey that that keeps them entertained
but also leaves them with with with something
something that sort of delights them in a special
way that is The Art of Storytelling that is the
um the thing that has occurred time and memoriam
since the cavemen were drawing on drawing on the
the sides of of the caves so it's the it's that's
that's what I'm speaking of speaking to and that's
what you do with with the screenplays the first is
this is the first brick in in building that wall
the wall where it will be projected
eventually it's the theater is the big
it's the big cave that we all we all huddle inside
I like that so it's not just the love of the final
product which is seeing these characters come
to life and getting an audience reaction to
will they laugh at this part will they gasp at
this part but also just the the real love for
crafting it and and ruminating over this word
or should this character enter here or there
well I think that all filmmakers and what I mean
by all filmmakers is that all all Crafts People
in the art of filmmaking from the writer to to the
production designer to the actor to the director
to hopefully the producers have a a
passion for telling stories and that's
where that's where everyone collaborates
that's where everyone comes together
because they go how can we tell this story in
the best possible way because everyone's excited
about that Prospect and that notion it's actually
a larger than it's larger than anyone one person's
aspect on on the production is no one is
the sole Avatar of that of that objective
it's like oh how can we tell this this great story
we're all excited about how can we succeed at that
do you think when a writer reaches a certain
level they no longer need to work on Craft no
just no that you got to remain teachable as a
writer it's I think it's extraordinarily important
you always have to be willing
to learn and I think that um
writers tend to give off this air that
they're like poor man intellectuals
I don't I don't think they
really are I think that they
I think that they they have to continually be in
a process in which they are allowing themselves to
be vulnerable and open to to new things I think
they do a good act and at seeming to be having
a wide array of knowledge there's there's
the writers actually do talk about this
there's a lecture that incidentally Tony
Gilroy gives where he basically talks about
how how writers have this amazing capacity
to know a little bit about so many various
subject matters but not never an extensive
amount about one thing we are I think in
a sense dilettante by by Nature in other
words yes we we have to be open we can't
there's there's no so you gotta you always
got to be practicing you always have to be
honing your work you're always willing to learn
from somebody else um there's I learned so much
from from other writers I love to listen to to
other writers talk about how they do things and
and and certain techniques and ideas they apply
I think any true writer is is a curiosity Junkie
um that there it's just it's just that they're
they're just need to keep getting more
information about whatever whatever it is how's
this work or how does that that's interesting
you know even if it just flies in one ear and then
out the other later we are curiosity junkies so
what is a poor man or poor woman's
intellectual what is that I like that
what I mean by that is it is like is is that I
think that writers do a good job of sounding good
of sounding like they know what
they're talking about I think um
there is a there's a kind of sometimes the kind
of intellectual arrogance some writers can have
but I don't think by Nature
being a writer is a is a
is a prerequisite or or any any kind of standard
for your intellectual capacity whatsoever
I I I just because you you have a large
vocabulary doesn't make you a professor
and and often I do believe others get that
confused including the writers themselves
so we believe our own height oh yeah Jack of all
trades now there you go there you go you just
explained it in such and and in terms that are far
more simpler than I just did hence hence hence you
know explaining what I was there you have it well
I think I'm further down on the scale I haven't I
haven't mastered total total intellectual but what
I'm curious is of how can we tell if we're not
teachable you talked about become being teachable
and that's something that we never stop getting to
that point where you've never mastered the craft
but how do we know how can we check ourselves
that's easy you just gotta listen
that's it if you aren't if you
aren't spending enough time listening
it's pretty easy that's that that's
how I think that basically you have
to check yourself if you're if you're
teachable you got to listen to people
you you you have to you have to listen to
what others are doing and if it jibes with you
that's cool if it doesn't that's fine you can you
can go and do your own thing but it doesn't mean
that you you need to block it out or you have to
discount it because obviously it works for them
and you don't have to hold any judgment over it
either you think there are times when we become
unteachable and then we kind of vastly back to
being teachable and and it's like this battle
I think that I think that that's a larger
life question and that that that um
that comes with a bit of wisdom as a writer if
you're if you're a young writer you may and you
you achieve a modicum of success you may start to
believe that you are you're beyond any kind of um
growth that you can't develop any further and at
your craft and then you you might turn around and
go no I was absolutely wrong it's like I do have
more to learn so I don't think that I don't think
that that's just a straight writer inquiry I think
there's a larger It's a larger question it goes
towards life and one last life question and that
is do you think having early success is a curse
these are deep philosophical
areas you're getting into
that's my own believing my own
hype but I am curious I don't know
because I wouldn't I wouldn't know the experience
of I mean either but I think that maybe I've heard
some writers suggest that they feel that they
were stifled because they received early success
I have experience I'm with writers and I've
known writers and and in Intimate ways that
I know that they've had issues with success
because it's a very it's a seismic thing to occur
and often you might get confused and
attribute it to to something that is beyond
Beyond even your even the product that you that
you put out there and if you do that then you you
can you can lose your way at at the thing that
you love to do the most or if that is writing
then you could maybe lose them lose a little time
um writing the kind of things that you want to
write and and developing the kind of projects
you want to work on but yeah yeah I've heard of
such a thing yeah it reminds me of one of one of
the scenes I love in the movie end of the tour I
believe about David Foster Wallace and the Rolling
Stone journalist that comes to his house in
Illinois interviews him for a week no I've never
seen that oh it's so good and I know it got a lot
of criticism I loved it I know there were people
that had their criticisms of it but that the David
Foster Wallace character says I cherish my regular
guyness that's something I really cherish and I
I'm just assuming that he meant sort of like not
believing the hype he was this Young Writers 24
I believe when infinite just came out and and
just making sure that he cherished that regular
part of himself again I'm I'm projecting onto
that but I'm I'm I just love that scene because
here's this young journalist played by Jesse
Eisenberg that's coming to interview him and
pick them apart and find out what makes them sick
and just the two bond is friends and it's anyway
for reminding me of that when you talked about
that so I have to see that now yeah I loved it
I mean there's a lot of sad parts to it but it's
based on a real interview that a journalists did
with him keeping with the subject the writer
who lands success with the first screenplay
is a fantasy mm-hmm why do we still think
this is different for us individually
what do you mean well so many people think
it's going to be different for me oh yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna this is different I know
other people took them 15 years to get this
one film made but they haven't seen my work
yet yeah it's I don't know it's really weird
it's it's a funny thing when people
approach it that way to this day I find it
I find it not only cautionary but I kind
of find it tragic that a lot of people
come to Hollywood or just in general um come
here with this hope this this this dream that
they can they can do this one thing and I think
that the trend has been for the last 30 years
about that you can write this knockout one time
screenplay get it to the right person and somehow
magically you will become a star screenwriter
I think that a part of that has to do with the
the the celebrity that has been attached to the
to the screenwriting profession recently well
when I said recently I mean their last
30 years it it wasn't like that always
it was a it was a very behind the scenes
profession and and now it has a a a
it has this this this heightened
patina of notoriety that people
aspire to it's like people wanted to come
to to to to go go to go to Hollywood in the
60s so they could become lead guitarists
for some band it's the same it's the same
elusive objective this is so gruesome but you
just triggered this memory of when I first came
to La one of the first things I saw was
a girl that had jumped from her balcony
and we may cut this but her body was covered
and the neighbors were all watching this is in
Hollywood and it was like a four-story balcony
and I never forgot that image because I always
wondered who was she why did she jump what I
mean she was living in this nice apartment much
nicer than the place I lived in but what
would prompt her and and I guess just a
reminder of that and being so young coming
here and seeing like this you can fall I
guess is the analogy yeah I know I'm going on a
gruesome take here but it never left me [Music]
no no I yeah who what what was her background
I mean like it's like my my circumstances
here are are well they're they're actually
quite convenient I'm from I'm from Los Angeles
I had no ever desire to to get into writing
or writing screenplays it just was something
that I was compelled to do I think and and
furthermore I wasn't compelled necessarily
just to write screenplays I started out writing
poetry and I just want it right I think that
that's pretty much the healthiest mode in which
anyone starts writing anything they're writers
they they want to write and then it then when
they they identify Oh I wanna I wanna I wanna do
a screenplay oh I want to really screenplay then
it's like oh great go ahead write a screenplay
I do I don't think your first screenplay will
is likely to probably get you anywhere but
if you keep writing screenplays you will
learn and and once you start to learn
you will you will hit a screenplay that'll we'll
turn some heads it's that's that isn't uncommon
that isn't a fantasy because it happens
it happens pretty much every day
that is not a fantasy what is a fantasy is if you
come out here with one screenplay and you're gonna
knock it out the part and you think that that's
all you need to do because that ain't happening
do you ever envision your script sitting in a pile
on someone's desk or maybe in their study on a
weekend and think what's going to make mine stand
out here what chance do I have yeah absolutely the
way I look at that and this is that the risk of
sounding redundant is I've talked about the whole
aspect of the voice but the the voice is one thing
but I in in my case I'm confident in my voice now
you go on you move on to that other word which is
confidence so with that with with with confidence
you what you want to do when you have like
a polished sample or a polished spec script
and that that you're submitting or or somebody's
reading or it doesn't matter who's reading it it
really doesn't because once you're once you are
mincing who what eyes are on your script you're
in trouble right there you you you you you need
to convince anybody and anyone that what you have
is as worth seeing turned into a movie so what
that means is you either you have either have to
knock them in the head punch them in the gut or
kick them in the balls and and and and and and
and and and and and that's something that you
have to be doing in The Narrative of your story
um and and if you are doing that with your story
you'll notice what I'm saying here is like it's
not just your script it's your story because your
script is a artifice that starts to make someone
believe that there are reading a a a a story
a a a a a potential movie something that they
get immersed in that they get lost in now if
you're not taking them to that place if you're
not creating that illusion with the words that you
mind to do it then you have lost from the get-go
from the beginning so that's if anything is what
I imagine if somebody has my my script in a pile
over the weekend and the thing is that what what
I enjoy about that thought or that that metaphor
is that I've had experience with running
the gauntlet of that metaphor is like
[Music] is like you when you like you're
like oh hey like let me give you that
Kunk that'll get your attention boom and then you
know you get the call you get the phone calls like
wow I love your loved your love your screenplay
wow that was amazing that really hit me I was I
read I read 200 scripts over the last five days
there's nothing more that you love to hear than
that you go like and yours got my attention
it's like it's like that is that is like
that's the kind well 200 might be a little
but a little bit people read a lot of scripts
in the industry and and that's because
there's a lot of stuff out there that
you gotta fight to get through to to to have
people recognize your talent as a storyteller
so you like I said you gotta whack them
in the head punch them in the gut or kick
them in the balls yeah okay can you can
you give me an example of a movie that
it's gonna whack them or kick them in the
nether region that that for another reason so
sorry another reason in case it's PG-13
whatever I'm censoring myself [Laughter]
can you give me an example of a movie that
if I saw an opening it would do that and if
that was the script I was reading I would
be feeling that to one degree or another
okay let me see one that I can think of well
just because we were just discussing it um
Michael Clayton is great because you
have you have a lawyer who takes off
his clothes during a deaf position immediately
I'm like okay I'm in it doesn't happen every day
I'm in what I mean this about I want to know
I'm curious right okay so like that's one I'm
always at a loss for like pulling examples
for for some films like at the at the drop
of a hat let me see if I can extrapolate I can
like if I go down the list of like for me of
of Tony Gilroy movies it's really actually not
so hard with him because like you can go to
like to The Bourne Supremacy which is amazing
opening one of the great openings where like
there's a Chase and they they find we're born
is where he's hiding out with his girlfriend and
his girlfriend dies in the first in the first
10 minutes I think of the film and I'm like
and you're like the stakes are so high at that
point it's this is this is what you have to
do with your storytelling most of the time
now now what I mean by that when I say like
oh um wax them in the head punch someone in the
gut or kick them in the nether region so to speak
is is is that it can be a slow burn too it doesn't
have to be immediate if it's a slow burn in it and
it hooks you you'll notice that sooner or later it
will it it has you in its grips to the point where
you're like where it'll do something that is so
enthralling that it won't leave your memory that
you won't you just you won't forget it it just
won't go away and and and and that is what you're
doing with storytelling if you if you are under
the if you under the notion or the idea or the
the misconception that you are you are trying to
Express something that you feel is well for lack
of a better term I think that that that that some
writers new writers they get caught up in these
masturbatory exercises of emulating certain other
writers and and filmmakers that they really admire
and it's just an Indulgence because they're just
trying to piece together the things that they that
they like thinking that that's going to make an
impression on the reader but that is not going
to do it what's going to make the impression is
someone getting lost in what you're telling them
and and and and and the way that you tell them
tell them it and if you get if you get caught
up in those kind of details you're gonna you're
gonna be in trouble you're not your people are
going to get bored and they're going to shut your
script because what really happens with readers
what really happens with Executives and producers
and people that have very busy schedules is they
take five pages of your script and they read it
and then they put it down if it doesn't hook them
you'll be lucky actually if you get five pages
you'll be lucky so those five pages whatever
you're doing in those five pages whether it's the
way you've written that description whether the
way it's the way that you've delineated those
characters whether it's a passage of dialogue
they have to they they have to be
firing on all cylinders or it's like
next becomes a drink coaster yeah next
next
yeah that's the way it works can you give me an
example and I'm trying to come up with a euphemism
for the term that you use but of of a writer who's
stroking their own ego a master of their domain
as you so well they're they're bad writers it's
like you you can't you can't take on you can't
take on someone someone who is successful because
more than likely they're doing something right
do what I'm saying so so so you you can't I I
can't cast dispersions against anybody that's
successful at what they're doing because they're
doing something right TN to get to get people's
attention so it's it it's simply just that
it's like keep keep people turning the page and
and and and tell your story but you gotta you
gotta keep them excited or they'll throw it away
sometimes I've gotten into the situation and this
happens a lot where where someone will say send me
send me a couple of screenplays send me send me
three free scripts or something like that right
now you have to be smart about that all right
because when you do that you go well maybe maybe
do you like this maybe or maybe they won't like
that and maybe they'll like that over here all
right so you send it and the and and sometimes
they'll go what I was reading I've been reading
pile of scripts and one of your scripts it's I
just didn't really connect but the other one oh
oh because you you what you're doing that's
the confidence I'm I'm talking about what
you're doing it's like well maybe they're not
this is not the sort of thing that they're that
they're in that that's their oath but maybe
this over is like that's a little conversely
on the other side of that of of this kind of
subject matter so so that's what the game is
that's what the the strategy is behind
the game the game is getting them hooked
just as you would be hooked if you were in
the theater watching the story all right
because if it reaches that stage like we said
if you're we're successful to get to that point
then you must be doing something right it must be
do even even the even the the the the the the more
lackluster stories still our stories how did you
figure out your voice I yelped into the wind and
no what I when you asked me that question
immediately the first thing that popped
into my mind and it really has nothing
to do with anything we're discussing
was the first few lines of James Joyce's
portrait of the Artist as a Young Man
and what that story and that book
means as a as a as a tale about
this this modernist Tale that is descriptive
of how an artist reaches his voice
that is descriptive in in the way that it tells
how that artist reaches his voice because anybody
familiar with portrait of an of an artist knows
that it is a it starts with these kind of weird
little phonetics because he's like he's just a
he's just a baby and he like he's like looking
out on a pastor and he sees cows and he's like
Moo Cow and stuff like that and it's and and then
it slowly develops into what becomes a language
that starts to become sophisticated which is the
the is considered like what people said was
brilliant about James Joyce and it is brilliant
also they said that James Joyce well
James Joyce apparently was a very
he was very very influenced it was like
he was the very first generation of of
novelists that were were influenced
by cinema cinema had influence
on writing the novel as opposed to and
that was early Cinema very early so now
yeah because I just got lost in thinking about
portrait of the artist it's such a good book
we'll put a link down it's okay so how I figured
it out I talked a little bit about that before and
that that really was kind of discovering how to
write in these terse sentences I already had a a a
sense of how to write decent dialogue and
I was I was just honing that along with
creating these little terse bursts of of
description to create the scene structure
that was working for me simultaneously
I learned how to outline
now outlining for me at that time was
something I used a structure of 12 Beats
I think it's a I think in the beginning the way
I worked it out and also the way I was taught
because there was various areas that I I picked
up some of this the skill set that I had I'd read
of course the art of dramatic screenwriting I
mean dramatic writing I also was very fond of
of some of David mamet's essays and books I I
took a couple courses here and there and so I
did distilled it down to writing a premise or
a log line for the for the the overall idea of
what the story would be and that that premise or
log line has the is is elastic in itself meaning
that it it can evolve it can change over time you
can always return to it and augment it in some way
as you are going through the writing process and
then for each of the 12 beats of my screenplay so
basically when I say 12 beats is if a screenplay
is technically 120 Pages there's a beat for every
10 pages all right and then you're thinking of of
the story and we're talking the story now as an
EKG all right so what I mean by an EKG and you can
also apply this to Christopher vogler's ideas on
the the hero's journey as well the EKG is like you
are you're lifting off with your inciting incident
the inciting incident technically should occur
anywhere from like the five page to to like well
in the old days it was like five pages for to 30
page but like it's really just five pages now you
really don't go farther than that and then and
then what you do is you you plateau off as you
get towards the towards the middle of the EKGs
so that's like page 60 and that means basically
that your characters or your protagonist is on his
way to towards his journey and so that's beat six
and then on on beat nine you are you are
you are coming all the way down on your EKG
you're spiking downward because they are facing
all their adversity and all of their obstacles
that they must overcome that they may never they
may never recover from and then if they do recover
and they do succeed and they win in the end then
that EKG comes all the way back up at 12. if they
don't if they don't win then that EKG comes all
the way up at 11 and then goes sharply down at 12.
so that is that is basically the that 12 point
beat outline now with the 12 point beat outline
each one of those beats one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve has its own
premise so every 10 pages or approximately
10 pages because you don't have to adhere
strictly to 10 pages because
maybe you have a shorter script
has its own log line so you go this is when such
and such happens such and such occurs cause and
effect to cause and effect statement that is
something that is that has a whole chapter in
loud Los hegres the the the art of dramatic
writing is the cause and effect statement that
goes all the way back that that can apply all the
way back to the Greeks and he takes it there so
so you you do that for each one of those
beats and then from each one of those
log lines you use those as a basis to to work on
to script those 10 pages or roughly those 10 pages
and then if you adhere to that you'll you'll
you'll probably get yourself a a first draft
it may not be much of a first draft but it'll be
something that you can you can rewrite and that
you can work on now that was my process back in
the early days and that's how I figured things out
once once you're writing the second draft once I
was rewriting at that point that's where I start
to apply a little bit of those tricks a little
bit of the fun stuff that's that's a whole other
bit of tools and things like that there's there's
there's refining that goes in with that sort of
thing you want to look at your script as what is
necessary in the story and what and try to take
out what is not necessary now this is one thing
that I do believe many storytellers fail to do
and it doesn't make them bad storytellers it's
just their choice but some some some storytellers
just overload their scenes and they just
want to do so much inside of the scene
and it's not that you don't need to do that to do
a movie to tell to tell a story for the service
of a screenplay that is to be interpreted into a
movie or a film does not require it to be a play
[Laughter] if you're going to be a play
you can make a play I write plays myself
as well I think that's fun but it's not
required it's a it's something that you
you it's a it's a story that you tell in pictures
um if I want to strike another analogy
that analogy for me is that at a certain
point for me and this goes towards the
root of the question is that when you get you
you you you you you you figure out your your
voice it becomes a lot like playing music
it's like you're not reading music anymore
you you while you play it you're
just kind of improvising a little bit
and you're you're just kind of like going with
the feel while you're you're jamming or whatever
and the classic example for me is felonious Monk
because the thing about felonious monk that
I loved that reminds me of screenwriting
is that he has this syncopation it sounds Ray
Charles too it's very it's also a great one it has
a single patient that it's not the it's not what
he's playing it's not the chord that he's hitting
it's what's between it it's the stop it's in
between it that that that that is where you feel
the story he's telling in the music and then the
same thing I believe applies towards towards a
good screenplay yeah yeah so it's within the cut
yeah yeah yeah I think he said the other thing I
like to talk about is telling the story in the
cut telling the story in the cut is is simple
it's a little simpler than than I think a lot of
people make it and I people tell writers and they
tell filmmakers and they tell directors you know
show not tell show not tell show not tell show
not tell and that can be kind of really confusing
because it's like you listen to those words and
you're like okay what the hell does that mean
what does that mean really show not tell okay
how do you show a screenplay I don't understand
what that means it's like it's like and so like
when you're you're a writer and you're like
you're hitting yourself with those words like
I don't get it uh I'm telling intrinsically by
writing you so you can be really confusing but
but what it acts is tell your story in the
cut because that is where the story actually
lives it lives in between the juxtaposition
of two scenes it it lives in the transition
of those two scenes so the period between those
two scenes is where all the information of your
story is uploaded so all the exposition that
you need to make in your story can be implied
it could be all implied you don't actually have to
say the exposition like like I would say like what
70 percent of your your Exposition
does not have to go into your script
it can be all in the in your cut because
all you have to do is like is is set up a
a visual cue with an action and then cut to the
end result of that action to the aftermath and
just by doing that just by putting one picture
here all right and then putting the end result of
that picture right over here you've downloaded
your or you've uploaded your Exposition done
so like the example I use is like is is
the is the girl like at the at the bar
at the at the hotel bar and the bartender comes
up to her and gives her a drink and then signals
towards a man at the end of the bar who waves at
her because he sends her to drink and then cut to
later they're in the in the in a hotel hallway
stumbling into her hotel suite kissing and we
know what happens we don't need to know what they
discussed at the bar we don't need to know what
their conversation was we don't know need to know
all the details in between we we get it we get
it and it's a really really simple technique and
not and and and and there are a lot of filmmakers
and writers that don't Avail themselves of it and
there are a lot of writers that do number one on
the list is Kenneth Lonergan who is a brilliant
writer and he knows exactly how to do that
and yeah William Goldman also knew exactly
how to do that so but but yeah it's um
yeah it's a simple thing more people need
to do it that's all how did you get better
at telling your stories within the cut
sometimes it was hard one because um
I had this tendency I think
like a lot of new Writers Do
to want to fall in love with their language and
to hold like some kind of like chunky like Diner
scene with like some interesting characters
talking and like throwing some colorful banter
back and forth and like oh how interesting this
is and when when when I started to realize that
it was unnecessary and that Not only was it
unnecessary that it was it was it was shooting
on me myself in the foot as far as it as far as
I'm grabbing the intent the attention of readers
it's not to say that those characters may not
have been doing or saying anything that was
interesting or fun or anything it was dropping the
ball in the ball game as far as like making making
my work stand out for others because essentially
what I learned is that and the the in the long and
short of it readers aren't interested in your
scene they don't care about your scene they
care about the story you're telling them that's
what they care about they don't care about your
scene they care about the story you're telling
them so if they fall in love with your story
they'll they'll they'll fall
in love with your script
they're not going to fall in love with your scene
they're they're not in it to fall in love with
your scene so yeah although there is something
very Charming about those Diner conversations
I can't I know I enjoy seeing them and then
you've got Marge the waitress all right what'll
it be and then then they she leaves and then
they're trying to like talk so that she doesn't
well that's a whole other I mean that's a whole
other discussion it depends on where it is and it
depends on how you do that sort of thing um is is
one thing and like for example my my favorite my
one of my favorite Diner conversations of course
is because it's charged you charge a scene you
charge a scene by telling it by telling your
story in the in in Cuts all right by by loading
your story like that heat yes excellent you
you you you you charge everything is very very
sparse and very um it there's not much
going on in heat other than the the action
the reactions the the setups for
the heist it's it it's very lean
heat and then it gets to that Diner scene between
Pacino and and De Niro and it means everything
that conversation that conversation means
everything and that's how you load those scenes
by by telling your story and then you come
to a scene where there is more or less a
standoff if it's not a metaphorical
standoff it's not emotional standoff
that's how you tell stories in general you can't
have that standoff in every scene of your script
otherwise you're confused about what you're doing
sure and then keeping it lighter I the 80s
90s sing-along scene which I don't know why
they used for so long where something's on the
radio somebody turns on a stereo and now the
whole group's singing together that seems to be
lost and I'm happy that that's the case I don't
I don't mind stuff like that I don't I don't mind
anything that's experimental like that as long as
everything else is tight you can do anything
experimental but if everything else is tight
it it it'll it will it will like rise to the
top okay I I'm a I'm a personally I mean it's
not my favorite film okay but I am a sucker for
that Hall and Oates scene in 500 Days okay all
right I am a sucker for that seat because I've
been that guy okay I I've walked out of that
swinging like that okay so I bid that guy so I'm
a sucker so I mean like so if you do it right
you it it flies it flies Big Bear Mountain
a weightlifting competition a stock broker
Six Sisters a plane crash three pennies gambling
addiction Friday at midnight benefits of hard work
a man on the Run and lastly this piece of dialogue
she ain't got time for that again
you don't have to use all 11. okay
you know I've actually seen some
some movies about these things
all right um
let's see um
well a lot of these are really classic and
I mean I'm almost inclined to like string
many of them together into like like the
strings some of them actually into like one
um
but I don't think I'll do that um
so like if I were to like take
something like like gambling addiction
I don't really think that that is a a cause or
an effect so to speak so you'd have to kind of
develop a cause and effect around it so so you'd
have like something like a a police officer
with
a gambling addiction
um
must
must um
resolve
his debt
to a
notorious
gangster okay
yeah bye
murdering his partner hmm
the officer's partner or the gangster's partner no
he's uh the the cops partner oh wow okay so what
that what that that that that creates is a cause
and effect it's it's not the cause is resolving
is debt it's not it's it it's not the gambling
addiction the gambling addiction is his I forget
what it's there's actually a name for it I want
to say misbehavior but I don't think that's the
correct one but it does not it it may predicate
the cause but it's not a part of the cause
the effect is that he has to he has to
to kill his partner which is kind of
effed up yeah so so yeah that's how that
one would work a man on the Run there's
so many men on the Run movies things that
always happens it's like the big cliche um
oh a man on the Run after
run after
a bank heist
um
after a bank heist hmm
and this is not the officer no no this
is different I'm different okay um
thank guys I'm stuck here after bank heist
I want to say but I don't think it's going to work
must reconcile this is Dopey with his daughter
ah
who ultimately
turns him in
okay it's getting interesting yeah let's see
let's take another one three
Lucky Pennies no or three pennies
retrieved from the bottom of the fountain
um
bottom of a fountain
bestow
three wishes
that reverse
into curses hmm
um
let's see
a weight lifting
competition foreign
[Music]
okay
weightlifting competition there's something
there's another element that needs to be
in there because there's no real cause
established a weightlifting competition um
a weightlifting competition
that's because it needs
a bodybuilder
entering
a weightlifting competition
competition
meets
his lifelong Idol
foreign
[Music]
premise feelings
competing
against him
after learning after learning so the
drama of course he's fighting cancer
what you want to do is you want to learn to
make that shorter for your kids out there
already Friday at midnight a young what's he do um
a young High School Dropout
um in
the 1950s
discovers
his
his his purpose
Fridays
at midnight
drag racing
all right
the
local
streets oh no dragging drag
racing on the off streets
of this small town
there you go yeah let's see what else we got here
let's tackle she got time for that
because that one's just weird [Laughter]
that was just odd so he dropped off of that
hey
a TV comedian
is
haunted
by the role
she played
on screen
and
is becomes
violently
ill
every time
a fan
utters
her famous catchphrase [Laughter]
catchphrase actually I'm gonna write this one
she ain't got time for
you don't even know this is this is
like this got Netflix all over it
yeah HBO Max and Netflix they're gonna be
battling that over she ain't got time for that
[Music]
let's see what else is here a stockbroker
foreign
and High Finance
on Wall Street
starts
selling shares
man
we'll just go from really
Fantastical starts showing shares
in the afterlife
done
um
Six Sisters
spurlonking
[Laughter] I'm sorry what does that mean
oh it's like it's cave diving oh okay
sure where this was going okay another region you
want to keep it Disney Six
Sisters spelunking okay um
get trapped
in
and
losing oxygen
come to the decision
of who lives or dies before someone rescues them
someone rescue
rescues them
foreign how many do you have left of our 11.
one two three wow I did all them great okay
can you combine the remaining three into
one log line yeah I'll try yeah okay um
actually this is pretty set up for
me right there to be honest good
this one it does have a Cause um
in in Big Bear Mountain
foreign ers
of a plane crash pretty it's
writing itself [Laughter]
must
save
the injured
through we'll just make it
simple through the benefits
of hard work
and cooperation
so which of which log line is your favorite that
you've created oh that's that's easy that one easy
it's a TV comedian is haunted by a TV comedian
is haunted by the role she played on screen and
becomes violently ill every time a fan utters her
famous catchphrase she ain't got time for that
that's a winner and why do you why does that
resonate so much for you well it's not so much
that it resonates it's it that that not at all
why it resonates the nature of a log line is is
is a couple of things and these many of these if
not all of these and I was having fun um violate
pretty much the strict rules of the long line and
and one of those is that is brevity a log line
should be concise that one's not so concise but
it does the other thing a long line should do it
grabs your attention so the so technically a
log line is is something that if you're over
a conversation over dinner you can say casually
to your dinner guest or to whoever it is or even
if you're just you're pitching it over dinner
and you can just let it roll off your tongue
and it have a sort of ring to it and a ring and
a varissa military then then usually or hopefully
someone responds to it like oh well that's nice
well that's interesting I'd like to see that it's
the thing that sort of makes you go I want to
know more and that's really the the objective
that's the purpose of a log line because it I mean
well okay I'm gonna I'm gonna back that up too
the log line also helps you design your screenplay
that is one that's an that's another purpose you
can use it for but at the end of the day when
you're done with your screenplay and you've
re you've refined your log line and you make
it concise you need to be able to give it to
the world and use it as a hook so a lot of the log
lines that you came up with you said they were too
long especially the one that you really loved that
it it's got to be shorter so if we were going to
take let's say the log line for Fargo I know you
said you liked the Coen Brothers work yeah or a
serious man or something like what what how would
we shorten that down because because that would be
hard a serious man that would be kind of difficult
to have a shorter long line with that I don't know
there I mean if you look up if you you there's
there there are smarter men than me that have
defined the log lines for for those films
and you can look them up you can Google them
and they they're very brief actually I've
read one for a serious man and it's it's
it it is kind of brief if you want to borrow
the allegory from something else to describe
like movies like that it's usually it's
not you don't have to reach too far um like
a a what is a serious man it's like a cancer
diagnosis leads to a journey of Discovery for
um a man that often considered himself invisible
and now comes to comes to a sense of rebirth
I mean that's that it it's pretty simple and
and what it is is like and if any writer or
writer who's a reader I would say is like when
they see a movie like a serious man or they
are familiar with the script serious
man they'll go well this is just
The Odyssey by Homer it's pretty it's the
same thing and believe me the comb Brothers
knew it was the Odyssey by Homer as they
were writing it it's kind of a blatant who
was PSY and the artist I don't know but I think
maybe the the I would say he was the Cyclops um
they've returned to the Odyssey again and
again the odd they actually did an explicit
interpretation of the Odyssey
with Oh Brother Where out there
or Brother Where Art Thou
is the Odyssey beat by beat
um remember John Goodman at the tree with the
patch on his eye he is the Cyclops so so yeah yeah
and so with this what would be the title for
this comedian who who's really just repulsed
by this famous role that she's known for and all
the fans want to repeat it to her what would you
call it oh well it's in the it's in the log line
it's the it's the capture phrase she ain't got
time for that okay and why why does that make
her ill why why does she not like that role
well it makes her violently ill um like physically
in in in the way I would foresee it so like
she would have actual physical reaction she would
convulse she would she would should and it would
become progressively worse and and manifest itself
and probably some very gruesome strange way and
and take it to its to it it's inexorable extreme
so have fun with it it's a it's a very humorous
premise and I I enjoyed that I rarely actually
write things like that but I also but I do
find those kind of things entertaining and
what I end up doing is usually this is like
I take things like that and I make them quite
serious along the way that's why I like the cone
brothers because they they're they're they're
they're satiris in a serious way quite often
do you feel movies today are less entertaining
than they used to be yes that's absolutely um
reason why is because I think
we're in a fallow period
for movie making and I think people are afraid
of taking risks and I think that a lot of movies
are cookie cutter and because of the way that the
business is structured right now it's a it's not
allowing for a lot of new talent to emerge and
and receive the kind of attention that it should
I think that there's periods where the pendulum
swings on that and that the opposite is the case
but right now we're in one of those follow periods
and hopefully it will swing in the other direction
in the in the 90s we had a very great night
amazing era I think it lasts a little bit into
the odds but after that it just went back to to to
to to to mostly Studio fair I have nothing against
Studio films by the way I think they're fine and
they're fun but you need to have other stuff too
and we don't have enough of the other stuff
70s we had a lot of that other stuff and
and now it's just another one of those periods
where we just don't have a lot of that other stuff
why do you think that is well it's just kind of
the way the business is is has been structured
and it's kind of like we had a new
influx of of of people in to the system
in the 90s from new kinds of producers
new kinds of Executives so that there's
there is a legitimacy that that independent
filmmaking received in which it was actually
actually was if not Prestige it it was given
consideration as far as being having money
making possibilities and some of those films
did make money but but now the party is over
the the the the movies that they that they acquire
at places like can and Sundance are already set up
it's like you don't you don't get in there on
a lark like you used to you're not you're not
you can't be OS Anderson you can't be a a Kevin
Smith out of the blue you can't be you you're
you're already you're already you're already fully
funded and backed by some kind of corporate arm
that allows you those kind of opportunities and
that's just the case there's once again I have
no judgment over those things it's just just
the way it is I'm hoping that because of the
streaming territory that we're in now that sort
of allows a little more wriggle room for that
for that to see the light of day in which there
can be new kind of new kind of talent taking
advantage of those sources but I don't see where
the evidence is of it yet hopefully there will be
do you think filmmakers are
forcing a message in today's films
I don't think that I don't think that there's
okay that's a complicated question
and I'm going to like answer it like this
I enjoy watching Martin Scorsese movies
and I really enjoyed watching the Irishman because
I thought it was a great great historical um
road map and it had a a greater message about the
the the American story and I am so glad that that
someone like that even though he has to fight for
it given his status as a filmmaker that someone
like that has the luxury to to to have that
kind of message that he can put forth in the
in his films but not everybody has that luxury
and not everybody has that kind of opportunity
and certainly the the the the the new Martin
scorses the young Martin scorses he's the
female Martin Scorsese the black Martin Scorsese
the Asian Martin Scorsese aren't getting that
opportunity and because they all have statements
that they want to make about America [Laughter]
and and those aren't those aren't
salable and and today's market
those aren't those aren't things that people
want to to necessarily finance and it is what
it is now I'm not saying that finances are bad
or or or or Studios or bed and they're they're
the boogeyman or anything like that I think
that's really a a horrible attitude to possess
um I think there's a lot of filmmakers that are
proponents of a sort of victim-like stance but
that does not negate the fact that the current
ERA we're in is not looking for a new voice
vigorously so the Martin Scorsese
that was able to tell the Irishman
how different was that person that told the
story of Taxi Driver traffic I really don't think
um much of a difference I mean I think it's
the same Spirit I think he's a he's a he's an
incredible filmmaker and he's he's he's evolved
oh yes yes but I don't think he is much different
but he was he he was able to solidify reputation
and I believe it was 1978. that the taxi driver
came oh this is 76 76 or 78 I think it was 76. it
seems like it was earlier yeah I'm not sure though
but yeah yeah so it was he was able to settle a
reputation then and he could he could go on and
and and continue to make personal movies like that
I mean the same thing can can be said for a lot of
people in that Echelon the same thing can
be said for for Spike Lee but even so Spike
Lee has to fight to get financing because he's
making movies that are about messages he's got
he's trying to tell he's got a message behind a
story I remember years ago when he was still alive
I was I was watching a panel on on Robert Altman
and and he said Robert Altman said it's like
someone asked him like in the panel like how do
you get financing for your film and he's like
I don't know I find it just I find it just
as hard to get financing as I think any young
filmmaker would this was like around 2000 he said
this and I and I tended to believe him you know
you you're you're you're you're you're an
older man who's trying to go out there and
get financing to make a movie that says something
and people aren't looking to to do that and today
you we know what kind of movies get made
it's like you're not they don't want it and
it's understandable it's a it's a business
it's a it's it's a business they're looking
for a return and that's the other thing that I
think that writers should be very aware of that
what they are in is a business now you can
consider yourself an artist and that's absolutely
fine I'm in fact I'm a proponent for that I
consider myself an artist be an artist if that's
what you want to be be an artist but don't get
mad if you realize you're in a business [Laughter]
because that's what it is it's they're they're out
there to make money they're not out there to make
art you're out there to make art they're out there
to make money so yeah do you feel like that's the
real test of how long you want to stay in this
business or attempt to stay in it is to realize
that well I mean I think you're you realize what
you do as a writer you you understand where your
lane is so to speak and that's not to say that you
limit yourself to to a track it's to say that you
are content and you you you're nourishing your
creativity and and wherever it is that you track
for like example for myself I write I
write screenplays and I also write plays
and I enjoy writing plays a great deal I
enjoy this theater I enjoy that experience
I enjoy working with actors in the terms of
stage but and and and and and and and and
working and and staging the work and and and
and and and and and and seeing it come alive
in a room full of people where it's not projected
on a screen it's a whole other experience
but this is the thing this is all under
the O of oh this is what I do as a writer
it's not under the ove of what I do as
a screenwriter so I at any one point or
time I can take my frustrations to writing a
play and go down the street get some friends
together go into a theater and say hey let's
hear this let's hear this out loud so I mean
that's that's my feeling on it and and there's
plenty of other writers that that that do the
same thing we've got we've got um writers that
that cross both Fields Aaron Sorkin Tracy Letts
David Mamet Susie Lori Parks these are all um
playwrights and screenwriters ask them what
they do Aaron sorkin's never going to say oh I'm
a screaming there it's like it's gonna go I'm a
writer I write that's what I do Sam can be said
for for other people that cross I'm I'm very the
other mediums of writing Stephen King Stephen
King's not gonna say yeah I'm a screenwriter
same again it's like I'm a writer Stephen
King's bigger than than any one movie so yeah
for a writer was never submitted to The
Blacklist how does that work the Blacklist
I think it's important to to point
out is you you upload a screenplay
to their website and the website more or
less is a collection of screenplays that
are written by anybody anybody can upload a
screenplay or a TV pilot to The Blacklist it
doesn't doesn't matter who you are where you
are in the world you can go ahead and do so
um those scripts are evaluated
now the the one thing is though
you're going to be paying a monthly fee and that
is I think the monthly fee is thirty dollars for
for that script to be hosted on the site and for
each evaluation you must pay a 75 dollar fee now
if you have the money to do that which for some
that can be a little tight to afford but if you
have the money to do that it's very much worth the
while because the Blacklist is probably the main
it's the Central Access that you will have to the
the the film industry on these days specifically
if you're not in Hollywood and you don't have
an agent or some kind of representation that
can submit your work and get you meetings if you
don't have any access to a representation agent or
a manager that can submit your scripts or get you
meetings so it's worthwhile to to post your script
on The Blacklist the other thing that's really
wonderful about The Blacklist is that the readers
there provide coverage for your scripts now this
coverage is is good in and of itself I mean of of
of its own to to promote the what what
a concise understanding is of your story
on your on your Blacklist page but it also is
a great tool for you to know where the flaws
are in your script so you can you can use it
as a balance sheet as to where you need to
fix areas that may not be communicating well if
you if you are a new writer and you are you're
you have trouble taking criticism critique or
receiving critique it's a great it's a great
um baptism by fire this is the the other thing
in regards to the Blacklist this is invaluable um
as you develop your skills as a writer you
have for you right there at your disposal
a barometer through which you can you can you
can understand how how strong your work is
so if you are getting recognition on The Blacklist
and and certainly if you're getting recognition
regularly on The Blacklist you that you're
ready to to go out into into the field or
to March out into the field so to speak so if
you are trepidatious about a screenplay that
that you are going to submit to
an agent or a producer if you
are a little unsure or uncertain about something
that you want to pass on for consideration to to
anybody try and see if you can pass mustard
on The Blacklist see if that script can get
get you a score of an eight or above if you are
getting an eight or above score on The Blacklist
then I think you can be entirely confident that
you that your script has has legs at that point
so I think that that that that's what also makes
it a wonderful tool it's a very good site um
because what it does is it it Bridges the Gap
between the industry and and pretty much anybody
anywhere it doesn't it doesn't exclude you out of
the process whoever you are and wherever you are
before on The Blacklist existed we had this this
Arcane version of that and that simply meant that
you had to be somewhat in the know or working at
some in some strata of the industry to be able to
get your scripts read by a reader at a production
company or an agency or what have you instead now
you can just go online pay the fees and have a
reader produce coverage for you that way in the
old days in fact they they sometimes if you were
submitting your script to a producer they'd asked
to see your coverage instead of your script itself
so that they could get an overview of your script
and you go oh well I have some coverage here and
let me let me send that on on to you you can have
a look here on on The Blacklist they can simply
go on to The Blacklist read your coverage and then
download your script so it's great and and and
and and and Franklin Leonard is a he's a really
really really really really
fascinating inspiring character
with what he's done here with his with his
website and also his his his advocacy and
support of people in all areas of the writing
field and his his strong stance on inclusion so so
I'm I can't say anything but good things about him
and his and what he's done for for the community
but what kind of feedback have you gotten on some
of your work that's made it onto the Blacklist
well I I've I've I've been
lucky enough to score high
a couple times yeah that's I've I've had
some good feedback I think I think that
as a writer you you it's incumbent upon you to
run that Gauntlet that you need to you need to
go on there and score high on The Blacklist you
I mean this is this is where this is where my my
my pride will come out or let's say my ego as
a writer where is like I need to knock I need
to I need to see this this this script this story
whatever knock it out the park somewhere so it's
got to knock it out the park on The Blacklist
it's got to knock it out the park on on the
on a on a spot on the Nichols Fellowship it's
got to knock it out the park on on say Austin
I've never placed on Austin but I'm just going
to say that it's got to knock it out somewhere
um once it's done that then I'm like okay well
I'm pretty sure it's a good script or I'm pretty
sure it it will impress somebody somewhere
so these are our tools today that we have
at our disposal at our fingertips
literally in front of us on our screens that we
can use as parameters for how good our work is
so they should be used you should use them and not
be not be afraid it's I know it it can be really
daunting to to receive criticism and to allow
others to look at your work but this is the thing
is that first of all you learn not to take
criticism personally that it doesn't mean that
you should necessarily change anything that
you're doing it it only offers you one thing
it's perspective that's it criticism gives
you perspective yeah now what does that mean
well what that means is that I can judge the
distance between what I'm going for and what lands
that's what that means so if I'm if I'm hitting
with something that where I was going for a Target
and I know it's hitting and I'm getting that
feedback from somewhere else an objective
Source I'm getting that feedback then I know
I'm on to something that that's perspective
if you if you're getting something that's
a little off to the side if someone's going
I'm seeing this as something else is
someone's misunderstanding it entirely
then you you might want to step back and adjust
you might want to go oh okay well I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm Gonna Change how this how the second act
sort of moves right here or I'm going to adjust
this aspect about the Beast story or I'm going to
um give this character a a long lost sister it's
it's convenient can be the difference
between a good script and a great script
perspective will give you that
perspective will imbue you with that
and when you have that experience you
never you never take criticism personally
in fact you invited and you want to know and
you're curious about people's criticism even
if they if they're not even if they're they're
they are to a certain degree misguided criticism
even misguided criticism can Enlighten you as
a writer and make you a better writer say I'm
a screenwriter and I upload my script to
The Blacklist and I pay my 75 dollars am
I just getting a one-time feedback some notes
or is that script now accessible to anybody yes
that is the case anybody can read the script
on The Blacklist what's cool about that is that
the the designated readers that you that
you pay for or hire to read your scripts
will will provide you with feedback but also the
people that or the industry folks that go on there
and may stumble across your script or see your
log line and just appreciate your long line also
have the option to to download your script and
they also have the option to offer you coverage
so that's a cool thing I think it's rare that
that ever happens because I've never received
coverage from someone that have just has just
been perusing my script or just downloading it
um off of the off The Blacklist now more than
likely what does happen though is that you you
you get a high score on The Blacklist and
that's when you actually get attention from
from from industry readers and they'll
and they'll download your script
in numbers but but and that's what you
want that's what you want to try and do
you want to it it can let me
tell you it can be expensive
if you're paying 75 pop as you revise your script
to try and make it better and better so you get
some kind of attention that can add up after
some time but if you do I'm I'm you score High
that can be offset by the fact that you're going
to have a lot of a lot of people downloading your
script because I just said did you get any
feedback and you said you you scored High
I don't know if we went into if there was any
negative feedback and maybe we don't
want to go there or well yeah I mean
yeah there's negative feedback but that but that's
but that's a part of what what screenwriting is
you need to get negative feedback at some point
you're not if you someone is not going to like
something that you've written somewhere for
some reason the what you need to know is why
that's that that's it you need to know is
why there there's a there's a meme that's
circulating right now that by by um that's
that features Jordan peel and Jordan peel says
you know how you handle criticism this is how you
handle criticism when I have a screenplay and I
send it out there and someone says there's
a scene in there it's just way too violent
I just it it took me out of the screenplay
I think you should do something about that
he's like I don't go home and take that scene
out of the screenplay no what I do is I go
back and I work on that screenplay and find
the thread that substantiates that violence
and I and I make that I I express that in a more
succinct and better way that's that that that's
that's what he says and I'm paraphrasing but but
that's basically what he is is expressing and
that's my my exact same attitude negative
negative feedback sometimes it's your best
feedback sometimes it gives you the best you
get breakthroughs from negative feedback yes
absolutely so I have a little bit of a writing
challenge we can try and I'm hoping you can
help me to make this small bit of information
better I'm going to read it to you so my story
is about a young writer trying to break through
whatever breakthrough means we'll call him Joe
and he's a good guy from a small town his parents
were hippie artists not a lot of money but they
supported his move to Los Angeles and so while
riding during the day and very tired at night
from these humbling like grunt jobs Joe meets
someone who decides to take him under his wing
and it's a producer who says what I like your work
and needs some Polish but I'm going to help you
and so the young writer Joe is just like wow
this is my dream come true I call my parents
and they say we're so proud of you we always
knew you'd succeed and then after about a year
reality sets in for Joe and Joe starts to see
that he's being used and sometimes abused and
this producer not only steals Joe's ideas
but he has Joe do a lot of his personal
Dirty Work like go spy on his tenants go spy
on his wife and also pick up his dry cleaning
and then he he has him writes skating reviews on
a former Nemesis and he takes those reviews and he
uses them as an his own because he used to be in
a literary world so he has Joe review some of this
other person's work and then writes these these
reviews and then he publishes them as his own so
how could we clean this up this is about like
a story of a young writer who's who's really
hungry to be in the business but he starts to see
wait a minute I'm in a bad element right here I'm
in a bad way for those of you who have worked in
the agency world this is the story of an assistant
okay is that the log line that's the long line
no it is that's what it is it's the story of
an assistant and it's the tame version oh okay
wow all right okay so mine's for all Auditors
okay great no it's true actually um actually some
you know some insistence would be like oh no it's
much worse than that but yeah no so what's the
what what's the purpose of this the purpose is
to show the good guy with a good heart whose
parents believed in him comes here and finds
that his goodness is taken advantage of okay and
and and my reflection on this is how can I clean
it up to tell the story better because it's
not just the idea but it's how I'm telling it
well it's first of all you have to
shorten the shorten how you say it
you have to you have to turn it into
a a concise bit of wording it has to
become a log line or a premise it has to
be something that you can issue briefly
that has a bit of a snap to a bit of a hook
something that pulls you in so that is number
one and so not to say that it doesn't have it but
you have to you have to find it in there a story
is is sometimes like like a block of marble and
and and you're the Sculptor and you have to you
have to find the form in the marble what you have
right now is marble and you need to find the form
um Michelangelo used to say I don't
know if you've ever been to Italy
but it's one of the most beautiful
things you've ever seen is the David
but Michelangelo used to say that he would look at
the the block of marble and he could see inside of
it to form and and it's proven that he he did
because at the Academia where the where the
the David sits it's flanked on both sides
by by his sculptures known as the slaves
and the slaves were unfinished because I think he
it was towards the towards the end of his life so
Michelangelo basically chiseled straight in to
the marble towards the form he didn't like like
other other sculptors Whittle all the way around
the marble Farm to get to the form he went right
to it so he'd be an arm sticking out of the block
there'd be a leg partially in the block and the
rest would be all just raw marble so that's
what you got there is a bunch of raw marble
and you have to get to the form that's inside and
the form would be your The Germ the absolute germ
of your story The Log line okay so maybe the long
line it since too long but it could be a premise
it could be it's a long line it would just be one
sentence correct yeah technically it's it's one
sentence sure or so it one or two sentences okay
so then Joe Young writer finds out that goodness
isn't always rewarded in entertainment
that's a little broad it's it um Joe um
a young writer is enthralled by a
mentor in the Hollywood industry
um and moves to Los Angeles to
find success and instead becomes
um and it is enslaved to a powerful man that's
more long launch of of what you're looking for
I tweak it a little bit more make it a little a
little better around there but yeah that's what
you'd be looking for okay and and Joe who would
he have as sort of his supporting character so we
have this producer who's like the Nemesis in some
ways and then would he have a roommate how can
we make Joe his dialogue was someone to actually
tell them about what's happening who would Joe be
bouncing ideas off of in this story I don't know
you you were telling me the story so who do you
think Joe would be bouncing the ideas off of it
sounds like you think there would be a roommate or
there could be a coffee girl oh sorry yeah there
could be a coffee girl and Joe could could be
going through a lot of things I mean the question
is who is Joe and who is Joe why is Joe you know
what what is what what what really motivates
Joe that all tells you a lot of things as well
you know that you don't you don't need to have
attendant cliches to to make any kind of story
in fact avoiding them informs who informs a very
sort of often often a unique way of subverting
them avoiding them it allows you to go down at
idiosyncratic Road where you start to come up
with some really original stuff so you sometimes
you want to get around that it's like what if what
what why is it why is it a coffee girl what if
he's gay that's true coffee boys what if it's a
yeah well it's a coffee coffee Point you know
roommate roommate why is he what if he lives
what if he lives with the with the with the
producer what if he lives in the producers
garage he makes him live in the garage what if
he sleeps in his car what if he sleeps in his car
now now if something's visually now I'm
starting to think what if he sleeps in his car
lots of lots of young people come out to
places and they're they're poor and they
and and they have to they have to sleep in their
car that's something I read about that's something
I hear about on NPR or the crummy weekly
hotel yeah yeah exactly exactly there's
there's all these other things you roads
you can go down to to avoid those tropes
and and it's good that you do because
you're going to get a more original
piece of work out of it okay so I see yes so the
cliche young writer with the the proud parents
back home that maybe that that's that's boring
okay so then what if we talked about what if
the dad had a gambling addiction and he gambled
away his college tuition and so he wasn't able to
get a creative writing degree so he comes here
to LA and it's not a coffee girl what if it's
someone who does drag at night at a club okay
and basically tells them the real deal and has
no we'll just tell him how it is and he he trusts
that person because they don't want anything from
him okay so then he basically says the the let's
say the drag is Terry by night and then Terence by
day and then so so make it interesting like just
not the typical that's beginning to be something
I want to see or read okay okay you see what I'm
saying right you're doing it you're you're doing
it right now you're going down those off-roads
and it's starting to make me curious to the point
where like oh that's something I haven't seen
before I'm interested in seeing or reading it
here's a here's a great test of of of
writing something or anything for any writer
and it's a simple one it's like write what you
want to see write the thing that you've never seen
before that you're like oh I really like to see
someone make a movie about that what what an idea
what what a novel idea I'll write the thing that's
never been done that I always wanted to see done
so then I have to ask what happens to Joe and
how does he ultimately reconcile with that job
or leave it and and then I have to plan out does
he quit does he get fired does something happen
to the producer does the producer get arrested
because maybe the producer had a shady business
on the side that no one knew about maybe he
was involved in Auto he was part of a ring of
automobile scams so he was in on it with doctors
lawyers workers comp all this stuff so he's in on
this and that's how he was really making his
money and that's how he's funding the movies
and then he gets arrested and there's a padlock
on the house and the garage and Joe's stuff is
inside he's got to get it out so the sheriff
has to come and let him in and then he goes
back home well yeah you could do that you could
do that okay you could do that as long as it's
organic as long as you feel that it's organic
and what you're telling me sounds fairly organic
but if it's not organic if anything happens
that does not seem organic to you as the writer
you should run from screaming in a run just
run screaming from anything that doesn't feel
organic and natural to the characters this is
something we haven't talked about is character is
that your character and what you've done is you
built up a character a character profile more
so than a long line or a premise and and through
that character profile you have you have you have
used that as a template to draw out what
potential actions would occur given that situation
so so now we since we know who Joe's character
is we we get a sense of how that will play out
character is a very very funny thing it's
very very funny and the reason why it's
funny is because it's prescient it's a it's
a it's a it's a cute little tool because
it it strings you along with like oh this
is the like it's not going to go where you
think it is but in a way it always will
so it's a it's this little trick it's
like it's like it like gives you enough bread
crumbs to go okay it's gonna go exactly where
you think it is but it it's gonna look like it
doesn't and that's what you do with character
you you you you you set you set up the reader or
the audience based upon the person's Behavior this
also works in tandem with with telling your story
in the cut and loading up your Exposition and
between those cuts because if you're if if if you
show the behavior of your character for example
and you'll see this and stuff like Lonergan
does this did this in in Manchester by the sea
it's like if you I go into a
bar and and I get into a brawl
every time I'm gonna go into a bar in this
movie you don't even have to see me in the bar
you know there's going to be a brawl happening
so so so that that's the sort of thing
that you can do with character that is that is
really really fun and is really really rich um
um yeah yeah that's basically that I
feel like my character Joe is too much
he's too much of a good guy like he needs
some kind of Quirk or idiosyncrasies he's
too like he's surrounded by interesting
characters but why would he stay in that
situation I feel like he's too flat
so I feel like I don't know who Joe is
he's just like this guy that's surrounded by
all these interesting people okay who is Joe
then that's what I'm trying to figure out so
so Joe maybe okay his dad had this gambling
addiction he found out that his college
education was gone so well if his dad had
a gambling addiction well he has to he has
to have some some serious resentments about
that and and those resentments probably manifest
themselves from some kind of problem of his own
um addicts have a tendency
to Tibet to beget addicts
and certainly have a tendency to beget addicts
and and the terms of Storytelling so that's a very
easy one to Target you can there's a ton of things
you can choose from other psychological issues
it could be it could be alcohol he could be
a cutter he could it could be numerous things
that you can use as as tools right so Joe's
not just gonna come out of the womb perfect
then from well you no he wouldn't no he wouldn't
come out of that perfect because he's he's gonna
he's gonna be resentful of his dad there there's
there there was a that dysfunction in this family
is going to be manifesting him even if it is in
even if it appears to be positive on the surface
the that's always fun to do is to do that little
ironic thing with a character where they where
the the negative aspect of that character looks
like it's positive at first but it's actually when
taken to an extreme it's negative would you mind
giving me an example Harrison Ford mosquito Coast
so it looks as a positive where he he's a he's
a good fought protective father but instead he
takes his his family to some like remote
location and like puts them through hell
you know you there's there's you can take
things that are good and you can make them
at their at an extreme bad at any time okay so
then maybe the movie opens with he and his dad
betting on football games and it's a father-son
bonding and you think wow they have such a great
relationship but then you realize that some
serious issues are happening he's owed money he
has a bookie that he owes money to and it's just
it's getting out of control but you don't see that
at first you just see this father and son watching
these games and you think wow that's really neat
like they have this close relationship yeah yeah
and and and and and and and and and and and and
and to a certain extent his father can be a good
father sure he could be a good father but still
be this kind of loser there's tons of there's tons
of humans like that sure male or female yeah and
so then I'm trying to think though how Joe would
be scarred from that but yeah yeah that I think
that's where my trouble lies with this character
is Joe is too perfect surrounded by some people
that they're not damaged maybe they're just very
interesting people and I've got to make Joe not so
one-dimensional I think that's my problem is that
everyone else is more lively than the protagonist
yeah yeah or you can do some crazy stuff let's
hear it well I mean like what I mean by that is
is that there there's there's other areas that
you can go you can go you can go down the line
like you're suggesting or you can start to get
meta with your character you can you can you can
trade off your character with other characters
in your story you can you can make it appear to
be about Joe and then it actually starts to
turn to be about somebody else in the story
sometimes sometimes like the Cohn Brothers will
give equal parity to some characters and you'll
go like I thought the story was about this guy and
why is it now about this guy and and and and and
and and and and and that's because they're Adept
at pulling that off not ever I wouldn't suggest
that a new writer should should go out there out
the gate and try things like that but you can do
stuff like that it it's the this don't you should
if you are if you are writing and you're having
fun and you're in the zone so to speak you
shouldn't you shouldn't be limiting yourself
on ways that you can tell the story if the
story wants to go there if it's organic
if the story doesn't want to go
there then you don't go there
hmm that's interesting yeah I think I really
need to rework this character because it's
not I'm not clear on who he is I feel like
I'm clear on some of the people around him
and he's not damaged enough or fully formed
see well well what would you do in this case
so once again have you written a screenplay
before I have not no okay so so how would you
approach writing this well think I would
try to outline it okay I would maybe do
I know what's been popular is this 24 I think it
was Adam Skelter talked about he had a teacher
that did the 24 plot points or whatever 24
24 beats or whatever which is the same as 12.
that's 12. okay all right it's just doubled
yeah but and so I'm gonna have the opening
of maybe on the couch and so all right we got
the the popcorn and all the stuff for the game
or whatever maybe maybe they're drinking together
Joe's over 21 and it looks like they have this
great moment so I'm gonna I'm gonna go from
there from that number one opening and start
and then we're gonna see some stuff unravel
at home maybe some yelling with the mom
and then the the hard discussion about I'm
sorry you're not going to be able to get to
yeah but after you're done with all that you're
and you get all those those points in there
you're gonna you're gonna write it right sure
in in screenplay format yeah okay so I may have
screenwriting software okay and then when
you're when you're done writing it you're
going to have hopefully something that's going
to be around like 80 to 120 pages right okay okay
then then once you have that 80 to a
one 120 Pages the whole world changes
and I don't mean just like I don't mean like
necessarily the world of script I mean your world
because you are going to come and
look at that script with new eyes
and and and and the new eyes that you bring to
that script is going to is is going to have a
profound effect on on your protagonist and that
main character none of every anything that you
that you come out with as a as an idea for like
an outline or thought like that is going to is
going to magically crystallize into the exact
thing that you want what happens at least to me
quite often is that I'll start off
with a vision of what I'm going for
and then along the way that vision changes and
then towards the end it really starts to really
dovetail towards the vision the original Vision
but not how I've expected never how I expect it
it dovetails towards the original Vision
but never down the road I expect it to get
that's when I know that it's organic because
I will sit there and I'll go like what
this is what I want to do you this is
what new writers have to learn how to do
to make the Sophie's choice between what you
want to do and what's best to do for your script
you might sit there and go like what I really want
to do this because this is how I thought of it
no no that's not best to do for your script what's
best to do for your script is this over here
because it's where your characters want
to go it's where your story wants to go
so you need to go in that direction
and you keep going into that direction
until it all falls into place
that's the way it works it doesn't work
any other way and I would defy any any
successful writer to to to to say to say
anything otherwise about that experience
it happens like that it's like you're
like wow it all worked out in the end
but never to a t but you have going on up here
okay so I won't really know
what I'm working with until I
take those 24 points and then I put them
in screenplay format write anything from
80 to 110 Pages or thereabouts and
then maybe wait on it a week or so
and then I really am working with the beginning
of the marble that's right okay that's right um
Ernest Hemingway had a famous phrase
and I'm gonna I'm going to I'm going
to use the the the sanitary version
what is that every first draft is
crap okay okay okay or poop right
yeah keep it yeah every first
draft is poop okay good okay
and that that is a perennial it'll never go
away from for time and memoriam for everybody
every first draft is poop even if you think
you're like oh this is great no it's poop
You Know You're Gonna Come Back and
you're gonna you're gonna look at it
and it's going to come together
the other thing about that is
and this is this is this is something every
writer should know really at the end of the day
with with my familiarity with the process and with
all the writers that I've known on so many levels
successful otherwise and everything
there's no such thing as a finished screenplay
that Medium never is complete you may
think it's complete it's never complete
a screenplay is finished when the director calls
action that's when it's finished there's no
there's no designated finish to a screenplay
and if a writer ever takes that for granted
it's they're they're not doing their job
writers should always be ready to come
up to bat and say I can make it better
or I can I can do this I can like communicate this
better I can do if you're if you're like on set
and the and and the director is is shooting the
film and and he says what tomorrow I'm about to
shoot these like five pages I I'm not feeling
it and the producer's not feeling it can you
go back and rewrite them you're going to go back
and rewrite them you're not going to say I'm done
okay you're not gonna go oh no it's finished
it's David Fincher it's finished David Fincher
I mean yeah that's all you that's all you get out
of me you're not going to do that you're gonna
you're gonna go you're gonna go home at night
and you're gonna rewrite those five pages for
David Fincher and you're gonna bring them the next
day and that's how it's going to go down so yeah
there's no such thing as a finished screenplay
okay and so is it is it when the director calls
cut or is it when he calls action or she
calls action because when it's when he or
she calls it action action yeah okay
it's like because they're shooting it
I mean for hopefully they don't rewrite your
your movie in post [Laughter] sometimes they do.